all right the green bay packers have let
their shareholders and season ticket
holders know
that this year if you go to lambeau
field for a game you got to wear a mask
and they're going to structure the
seating to permit social distancing now
look there's still no guarantee that
anyone's going to be able to show up for
any games but this is a very tangible
sign that it will look very different
now some teams i think are going to take
the approach it's not worth the trouble
of trying to keep people apart and have
staggered entry and staggered departure
and enforced mask wearing but this is
where the packers are they're not going
to surrender that revenue they're a
publicly traded company with a duty to
their shareholders and their duty is to
maximize revenue and they're not going
to let that revenue just walk away so
they've let it be known to their season
ticket holders that's what they plan to
do but the one thing we've learned in
recent weeks
whatever your plan is your plan subject
to change the virus continues to control
the situation and the virus is clearly
in charge and the virus continues to
spread the past couple of days have had
record high cases of the virus
in our country and this fourth of july
weekend if people aren't smart if people
don't wear a mask if people don't
socially distance if people aren't
conscientious about
avoiding
getting and or spreading the virus
it's only going to get worse
and football season's already in
jeopardy
i saw the report from dan graziano
vspn.com about what was discussed
yesterday when the nfl pa player reps
had a two hour conversation
testing and contact tracing are going to
be the keys to determine whether or not
the season can happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports